what you see hi Cory well you know as
you know Google supports you know
thousands of different devices phones
tablets laptops sets up boxes today was
really about the flagships and and front
center were those two Nexus phones you
mentioned one from hallway the 6p one
from LG the 5x you know both run the
latest software lots of bells and
whistles they have a fingerprint sensor
sensor on the back but these are Nexus
devices so Google does not sell them via
wireless carriers the the larger one
from hallway starts at four ninety-nine
a smaller one from LG 349 so they're
expensive and the question is and it
always has been for Nexus devices who
are these for they reference designs for
other hardware makers or is google
really trying to go after the high-end
android market which of course samsung
has controlled listen in as i asked Dave
Burke the VP of Android that question we
started first back at the software right
we create android and so our latest
version android 60 no marshmallow is is
rolling out next week and so to create a
you know an actual mobile operating
system or platform you can't do it in
the abstract you actually to build
hardware that hardware needs to be
really good you need to be carrying
around day in day out really perfecting
the software on it so first and foremost
that's how axis was born but then second
what we realize is we can also showcase
the very best hardware the very best
software hardware integration and sort
of inspire others to do their job so you
talked about sensor hub it does seem
today and lots of the things that you
debuted that computer Google's trying to
make computer science and machine
learning turning it into a competitive
advantage right a benefit for users one
of the one of the nice features you
showed or is is how apps can become
aware when you use them and present
themselves at that particular time of
day how deep of a competitive advantage
is that for Google visa be some of the
other platforms that are out there yeah
I think like machine learning and deep
flirting as it's known these days is one
of the big strikes of Android if you
look at how Google photos works like for
me it automatically can detect my my my
1 year else face and like if I scroll
back at that in history it goes back to
the very first photo that was taken
literally three seconds after she was
born it's just amazing how this
technology works you know Google's
dreams are cloud based company so when
we say we were integrating software card
or actually really integrating hardware
software on the phone and the cloud we
want it all to be very seamless so I
have to ask you google as it has been
for the past few years has been under
tremendous scrutiny from regulators in
Europe in the u.s. around its
administration of Android how much does
that constrain the innovation when we
think about on droid first and foremost
it's an open source platform so we
create the code and we make it available
and anyone can take it and then from
there there's a set of Google
applications one of the things that
we've done on the new Nexus devices this
is something I you know we've been
working on for quite a while is a new
service that basically means that when
you're setting up the phone we try to
move as many of the non-essential
applications to get installed post set
up the result is you can then uninstall
those applications just like any other
app and that's sort of the approach that
we've been we've been taking and you
know from there you know people ship
Android devices with and they bundle
whatever services they want on top of
that it's an it's an open market can
make an app that they need so brenna you
know people are that's what the Apple
events are like can you compare our
Google event I can't imagine i has the
same sort of gee whiz buzz feeling no
it's completely different I mean it's
much smaller you know Apple packs those
events with employees with you know
visiting dignitaries they rent out huge
halls the google event was small but in
a way it's more authentic you know
they're they're talking about the
products they're talking about what they
feel their advantages it their
advantages computer science deep
learning the purpose and the point of
the nexus devices of chromecast you know
it's two hours and you're done so a
little less drum roll around it but
you could or you could say that it's the
less effective approach certainly Apple
gets a lot more attention for its events
so no one's going to stop you on the
street ask you how it was well I wonder
if that's the nature I mean should we
even care about these things because
there are so many more devices such a
wider variety of devices that run on
Android that even even Chromebooks and
so on that the hardware is not the thing
the software is the thing well look I
mean this is you know company like
Google is sending a message to consumers
obviously you know it wants people to
buy these devices but it's also speaking
to partners and Android in particular
has become this unwieldy thing rare very
fractured as you know lots of companies
building low-end devices and doing quite
well maybe not profit wise but selling a
lot of devices and then that kind of
massacre on the higher end where
companies like Samsung are having
trouble competing with apple and so
Google you know it's holding this met
this event it's sending a message to
partners and thank here's what's
possible you know with phones with these
designs integrating new technologies
like the fingerprint on the back of the
phone very different than you know where
Apple places the thumbprint on the
iPhone so it's about talking to partners
and it's about expressing Google's point
of view you know how it views these
authenticating technologies how it wants
funds to be more aware of users
preferences